let's talk about jen saki i know you
guys like it when i
when i talk sake when we do clips about
sake
they go bananas because people cannot
believe this woman this woman
lies and lies and lies and lies and lies
she knows she's lying we know she's
lying she knows we know she's lying and
she continues to lie
that's what liars do and we're
surrounded by a lot of them these days
uh well now she's sort of already
laying the groundwork for the federal
government the biden administration
to endorse states doing more lockdowns
and i guarantee you it's coming guys
quote me on this on july 7th
2021 dave rubin says more lockdowns are
coming of course they're coming
because the last year and a half was a
test how quickly
would we all fold and basically we
folded quicker than a wet paper bag
we just all went down and you know we we
all have blame on us right if
trying to figure out who to blame just
look in a mirror and i would include
myself in that
we should have fought harder from day
one you know we all we all did the two
weeks to flatten the curve thing
and then they just ran with it and ran
with it and any and on the top of the
fact that we now know
that lockdowns just didn't work they
they work to destroy the economy and
wreck
lives and cause depression and
alcoholism and a whole bunch of other
problems
but they did nothing in effect to stop
kobit well here's sake
talking about how biden would certainly
support
states locking down once again if the
number of cases continues to trend
upward are there any circumstances under
which
the white house would reimpose some of
those restrictions
um as cases tick up or would that be up
to the states
well states are going to have to make
evaluations and local communities are
going to have to make evaluations about
what's in their interests and as you
know there are
much higher rates of vaccinations in
some parts of the country over others
and we certainly support
their decisions to implement any
measures that they think will help their
community safe
okay so on one hand i'll try to give
credit where it's due the answer there
the last basically
the last sentence that she says there
where she's going to say we're going to
let the communities do their thing
you guys know i'm a states rights guy
right like so i want local communities i
want states to make decisions
for themselves so a guy like desantis
can do the right thing in florida
and a guy like newsome can do the wrong
thing in california to me that's a
better option than saying that the
federal government should tell
everybody what to do so i will give her
credit there
on that but that's not really what's
going on here and i would also argue
that the question i don't know who it
was that asked the question but it seems
like a very leading almost like a
planted question
to lay the groundwork for future
lockdowns like nobody's talking about
lockdowns right
now is anyone in your world anyone that
you know that you're married to that you
live with that you hang out with that
you had dinner with that you go bowling
with
is anyone being like oh we're gonna need
more lockdowns or is there
is there anyone out there really that
even the people that are
triple masking still and they've had 18
shots and everything else
going oh if if it gets worse we're gonna
need lockdowns again
so the idea that someone at a press
conference is sort of tipping to them
like
is there any way that you'd kind of
support lockdowns in the future like is
that something you do
it just seems like a very odd question
to ask but anyway i'll give sake credit
on the second half of it which is
you know you leave it to the local
communities the bigger
issue though is that we know lockdowns
don't work
so why say that like you could say yes
if there was evidence that lockdowns
work we would leave it to the states
because we don't want to use the power
of the government
the federal government to do everything
for everyone at all times and as i've
been saying for a year and a half if you
live in
rural montana the regulations
and the way that covid might spread is
going to be very different
than it would be say in metropolitan new
york city
but there's no evidence that they work
so why would we ever tolerate this
and that's why so much of this had very
little to do
with a virus with over a 99
recovery rate and a virus that basically
everyone who died had a comorbidity
and had either cancer or heart disease
or diabetes and that's not to diminish
any of the people
that died and we all know people that
had covet and i know
actually many people in my family had
coveted and everyone survived and i have
many friends
that had coveted and everyone survived i
actually i'm not even sure
about my own antibody test but i was
sick a few weeks ago maybe i had covered
i don't know here we are
i'm okay life goes on but the idea that
we would
ever that any of us regardless of
whether you live in florida or new york
or anywhere else
that we would ever give the power back
to these authoritarian lunatics
to keep us out of work to keep us away
from our family to stop us from going to
funerals i mean the litany of horrible
things that they did while gavin newsom
spent 20k on a bar bill at french
laundry and while gretchen whitmer who
told people
she didn't want them to be gardening
outdoors in their own house in michigan
while she was getting on a yacht and
lori lightfoot was out there protesting
in chicago without a mask while locking
down her state and i could go
on and on and andrew cuomo sending the
old people back into the old age homes
where they all died and what's happened
with that is he going to jail like
what's going on here
the point is it's not whether the states
should have the power the federal
government should have the power i think
you know what i feel about that
the point is this [ __ ] does not work
not only does it not work we know that
once you give these people the power
to shut down businesses to say you have
to be at home by 10 o'clock because
covet doesn't spread
from 10 p.m to 6 a.m or the rest of the
nonsense they will gladly
keep taking the power so as i said
before we all kind of failed the test
and if we don't want to fail the second
test
the second test will be hey if we do it
to you all over again
deja vu all over again are you guys all
going to fold and bow immediately